thank you everyone for joining me here
today my name is Jeffrey Huntley this is
myself in the speaker lounge two days
ago when I got Bob did my peers saying
you have to write a talk and present
today so bear with me
I'd like to introduce you and to
something I've been working on for the
last couple years and that is a project
reactive UI reactive UI is a set of
extension methods on the reactive
extensions and we cover nine different
platforms primarily net but we cover all
the mobile platforms even even
televisions so Samsung Tizen televisions
there's a pull request open right now
we're adding support for the platform so
you can do reactive programming with
that we also have a universal Windows
platform you WP windows forms a lot of
people still using window forms I have
one person who says reactive UI is the
only thing that makes him like
programming in Windows forms so I still
support it for him
now reactive UI inspired the creation of
reactive cocoa and reactors swift
reactive coca was written by a github
employee and reactive UI I did not write
reactive UI was written by Paul Betts
also a github employee so ever much
coffee and beer they ported the concepts
behind reactive UI across and it's close
to 14,000 stars on github and it
literally changed the way an iOS
developer writes applications so it's
not just me there's a team behind the
reactive UI it was created by Paul Paul
created whilst at github and a couple
years ago he departed the project he
actually crossed over into the
JavaScript ecosystem and he joined us to
become the lead engineer of slack and
wrote the desktop application that you
use on Mac and Windows and
that is using electron we also have Kent
who's here in Australia in Adelaide
unfortunately couldn't be here today and
we have Brendan foster someone very very
near to me special the project has grown
to maintain us it's the beginning of the
year and we're growing if you're looking
to get started an open source we'd love
to have you on board we have an
ambitious roadmap so some exciting news
last week is reactive you I joined the
dotnet foundation and this is going to
allow us to do some very very
interesting things
I can't wait to like share these with
you so this this journey myself into
open source started three years ago when
this guy Brandon you'll find him
downstairs at the github stand he wrote
a blog post he said I'm setting aside
some time each week for mentoring
developers that's the kindest thing you
ever said I couldn't believe someone
working at github was going to set aside
some time for pair programming and in
what he wrote was I've been fortunate to
have many great mentors in my program
career just about site is off sometimes
there's software sometimes is not but
someone being there so we set aside at
that time so I dinged him on skype and
this took unbelievable amount of courage
I was enterprise developer I felt like I
was at my ceiling I was stuck like I
knew I had to get out of that job and I
just didn't know what I needed to learn
to get out of that or how to find the
joy in software development again and I
dinged up in Skype it took huge amount
of courage and finally someone was
challenging me I I was in over my head
and he was there pulled me or pulled me
up I was learning so fast the pace was
intense
Brendan plugged me into something that
changed my direction software engineer
and that's reactive programming and I'd
like to do the same for you a couple
weeks ago I started
a lot of live coding and programming on
YouTube and it's you see over there the
light in the background that's um a
Philip shoe globe and when I'm on erred
automated turns red this is kind of cool
so Aaron my wife that is here she
doesn't accidentally run into the room
when I'm broadcasting and I'm teaching
everything I know about reactive
programming but not just reactive
programming maintaining a large open
source project that's used used at
github a slack elasticsearch and a bunch
of Huff has it everything from
continuous integration how to take a
dotnet what net standard is how to cross
compile with a new vs 20:17 project I'm
there teaching it I'm sitting so
sometime like Brendan did and I hope you
take me up in the offer if you go there
it'll redirect to youtube and you can
follow so nine years ago artists me and
a bunch of four people they they
embedded something the reactive
extensions and what Brendan showed me
was this video on duality and reality is
in mathematics something of a complete
opposite and but who has huge done three
talks and I highly suggest going back
and looking at these talks they invented
the reactive extensions and what they do
on this whiteboard is they pull apart
it's so mentally stimulating they pull
apart reactive programming and show a
collection a list of lists of objects
where you would normally pull you
normally pull from the collection one by
one and they show how they reverse it
they actually reverse and in turn it
from a pool operation to a push
operation there's two videos at it's
mind-blowing
and that was the birth of the reactive
extensions at the time there was a
project called Volta and it volt we
within Volta they had some very
innovative stuff going on but they
discovered something and they extracted
that summing and it became
the reactive extensions and this this
was this was in 2009
so there's many shapes of data you have
what single values and multiple values
you also have the notion of time you
have synchronous and asynchronous for a
single value as a single value as
synchronous it's just an object so you
knew up a class for multiple values at
synchronous you have an iron numerable
so a list of T so it's iterative all you
do a getenumerator likewise and just
coming in recently in the last couple
years we now have a sink and a weight so
this is when you have a single value
that's asynchronous and this is the most
common use of asynchronous programming
in dotnet now but there is another one
and then Brendon introduced me to it
through that video and that's I
observable observables
so we reservable x' they're asynchronous
and they return multiple times and this
presentation I will show implementations
of observable that in desktop
applications and mobile applications and
it would make you really think that this
is really useful really really useful so
if you sick of investing time and energy
and learning how frameworks work and
you're looking for some direction
instead of investing time in learning
angular one and then having to throw
that knowledge out learn something
Universal and reactive programming is
universal in the sense that on mobile
reactor program is used extensively in
the Android ecosystem on the desk on the
backend it's used in stream processing
on the front end on the front end you
now need to need to know it as part of
rxjs
very very popular over there so if you
learn reactive programming what happens
is you just apply the concepts that
you've learned in to a different
implementation
so it was created in dotnet in in 2009
and it is implementations in pretty much
every conceivable language known and
rxjs has become incredibly popular last
couple years so an example of example of
investing knowledge into reactive
programming investing knowledge into a
framework is developers learned angular
1 and all the sudden angular 2 came out
and had to throw away all their
knowledge because they invest a time to
learn those api's of a reactive
programming so Wester time to learn
those api's and interesting enough the
change that happened was angular's
embraced reactive programming you now
need to know reactive chrome to be an
angular developer so only reactive
programming allows you to express the
idea in a single place and this is
something that's really really really
really cool but it also scares people
away at first because it's just so terse
like it's just it's all combined
together you declare your intent of what
you want on a single place on a single
line instead of having lots of event
handlers in your application you're
scrolling up and down to figure out what
you're going to do it's all declared in
a single line so it's actually easier to
debug because you're not scrolling
through your application and different
locations but it can look scary at first
reactive programming can look very very
scary at first and the best way to look
at it is actually Microsoft Excel
reactive programming is Microsoft Excel
instead of telling the computer what its
job is instead of telling the computer
take a and B and then put it in to see
what you're doing is you say C should
update anytime A or B
update and that's the main thing about
reactive program is just thinking around
how you describe to the computer what
the end outcome you want to occur so
reactive programming has inspired two
much-loved JavaScript frameworks one is
Elm and the other is cycle Jo
and these are the equivalents of
reactive UI in the web space so here's
an example like a concrete example of a
problem you have when you don't use
reactive programming you have a view
model you have a is busy property and
that's a display is a loading indicator
a loading indicator when it's enabled
you have a load command and when that
load command is executing it just turns
that indicator on and off and this is
really common I bet you would find it in
your code base today you just turn on
and off and it's really really simple
until new requirement comes through and
you're all of a sudden you've got a race
condition in your code and this is just
a simplistic loading and saving but it
can get really really complicated this
branching of turning this on and off in
your code it's really hard to debug and
handling this complexity is scattered
all over the place but we're reactive
programming that's all defined on two or
three lines just like microcytic cell so
here's an example from a code review I
did last night and it's a mobile
application written in xamarin and it's
a loading loading and saving scenario
and the question is what happens if both
of these are executing what would happen
to the navigation in this mobile
application and that would have to be a
crazy fast typer for this is a problem
that's a review comment you have to be a
crazy fast tapper and it's like okay
well let this pass it's true you have to
be a crazy fast tapper for this to
result in a user defect but if you
defined when if you defined when that is
busy should be on and off like an Excel
expression or Excel macro you wouldn't
be in this place in the first place
anyway so I'd like to introduce you to
win any when any is I built him within
the reactive UI it's uses observables
and it's a bunch of extension
methods now Paul converted when any over
to typescript it is now available like
if you afterwards come to me I'll show
you where but he ported supporting a lot
of the concepts behind reactive UI to
typescript it's kind of cool so when any
is when any allows you to say when the
when a dinosaur has scales or has horns
or has spikes or has a club what I'm
saying is when any one of those
checkboxes changes I'm subscribing and
listening to the events that occur it's
like the Excel expression they sell
macro then I go to decide what I do when
that happens so I'll show you the code
behind this
this is when any so it's very very much
like a Excel macros Excel expression I'm
saying when C changes but so when a lb
changes see should something should
happen with C so here I'm listening to
the the weight of the dinosaur does it
have a club it have a horn and then I
compared it to the dinosaur on the right
and it just assert determines who wins
like rock-paper-scissors
so it allows you to subscribe to change
notifications that are occurring or
sequences the next primitive that's
provided in reactive UI is reactive
command when you're building
applications typically you use I command
and I command is something you bind to a
button but my command is missing some
things and what reactive command does it
provides a bunch of observables you can
subscribe to to compose an outcome first
up we have can execute and can execute
it's really cool is we can pass the can
execute into the I command and we can
make the I command or the button
automatically disabled if that ever
becomes true
likewise we have is executing exact same
scenario there we can automatically
disable or enable the button based on
subscribing to these results and what's
extremely cool about this using induce
it allows you to compose situations like
this building on the knowledge of when
any you can go when any the username and
password is not null or string or empty
the login button will activate
automatically and that's using when any
so I do when any the username password
is not blank that sends an observable
that are subscribed to saying it's true
which means can execute is true the
button automatically changes to enabled
and can be enabled and it's perfectly
efficient I don't have to go but an
enable button disable it just subscribes
to it just like Excel it just works and
which means you're doing less screen
redraw so it's more performant
so here's the example I use the name
blank password blank button
automatically updates so when any
username password button enable and
likewise I take the is executing
observable from the login button and
that's connected to the can execute off
the cancel button so right now I can
cancel the cancel button automatically
enables and disables when the login
button changes the state of login button
changes super cool
on line 25 is an example of when any
when the username or password is not
null I pass it into I pass it into the
login and it allows the login to be
enabled so these are these same concepts
even though this is dotnet this is
reactive programming this is what you
can do reactive UI is a set of extension
methods that allows you to do this so
you can compose an outcome and luckily
due to xamarin this means it runs on
mobile on all mobile ecosystems the next
one I'd like to show you with an
application of reactive programming is
from a library called a kovash a kovash
is a library used extensively in the
dotnet ecosystem it's a key value store
as a cache and a lot of people use a
kovash kind of the wrong way oh it's the
right way but it's the only using 10% of
its capacity so if you imagine that you
have an application for Twitter for
example you'd normally have a loading
indicator and you do a network request
and then you just play a list of tweets
people normally use a kovash and
implement it like they implement it to
do show the indicator on do a network
request which blocks use the interaction
and then display the results because
they're using it as a future a single
value a kabosh is built on as herbals it
allows multiple values over time why
this is cool is it allows you if the
user loads up the Twitter application it
does a request if the if the if the
cache result is in the cache it returned
immediately there's no need for a
loading indicator what you're doing is
displaying the displaying the tweets
straight away to the user there is no
loading indicator needed this is one of
the properties of multiple values over
time what it allows you to do and then
what you do in the background while the
user is scrolling for their tweets cuz
you know and they might have been some
background services updating the cache
and they might have 2,000 tweets or in
there that unread you can actually use
this to say go fetch the latest version
from my from my endpoint and then from
there when that data comes back you just
compose the result you create a set and
you append on the top the user doesn't
even notice what's happened but a whole
bunch of magics happen and you no longer
blocking user input and this is some of
the properties of what as ervil's allow
you to do I get really annoyed when I
see loading indicators it's not needed
you don't need to do it display the old
data the user was using and then
insightly in the background
retrieve and refresh it should be the
loading operation should be passive to
the user the next thing I'd like to show
you is a servable from a bad pattern so
who uses event handlers same thing
applies for if your JavaScript you
working with the Dom you subscribe to
the Dom in the Dom events so Zobel from
event pattern converts event handles or
events into observables really really
cool because you can compose outcomes
with this so within a reactive UI we
have a we have a we have a project cord
a vent builder and what a vent builder
does is it generates all of the
reservable properties for that
particular platform and you can use it
to compose an outcome so I'd like to
show you an example of subscribing to
events in a WPF application that does a
cheat code that's very popular in
computer games
all right so I'm going to go up up down
down left right left right a B
at the sequence it's works it's great
and the actually implementation of this
is like promise it's all defined in a
single place it's not scattered up and
down you're not listening to a bunch of
event handlers you can you can now map
the world they could be keyboard
sequences they can be mouse clicks they
can be data coming down from a REST API
could be GPS coordinates or locations
they're all compatible they're all
events that can be converted into
observables when you have an observable
where you can use when any to derive an
outcome cool so what we do here is on
the main window for WPF I have an events
extension and anytime there's a key up
event I'm selecting the key and then I
put it into a window of the last 10 keys
and then I compared it to the sequence
for the sheet code and if it matches
it's the sequence if it's dot it's not
so this was contributed by Brad many
years ago I was one of his first
contributions to the reactive UI project
and I learned this only a couple days
ago I didn't know was him I thought Paul
wrote it but Thank You Brad and in that
it actually the inspiration behind this
came from F sharp which is cool so
another thing that's cool we've reactive
programming is schedulers is time a lot
of people don't handle time correctly in
their mobile application or even desktop
applications time is a gigantic bag of
mutable sadness it's really hard to test
most people in dotnet due date time now
right and soon as you do date/time dot
now or thread dot sleep ten seconds you
you're tightly coupled to the computer's
clock and it makes testing really really
hard so in reactive extensions this is
thing called schedulers and schedulers
it's like a
virtual clock so now imagine that you
sitting down for an interview and this
is the programming challenge they've
given you I got this couple years back
it was interesting the lights will
change every five minutes
simple enough their traffic lights
provide the output for the light changes
that happen between 9:00 a.m. and 9:30
okay that's simple enough you must
provide all unit tests for this program
and challenge and what they are
specifically looking for here is how
fast a unit tests run how fast the unit
tests run for the traffic intersection
if I tightly coupled to date timed up
now and did it in an imperative form
these unit tests could take a very long
time to run they would take 30 minutes
to run but the implementation using
reactive programming was simple it takes
execute the test of the test executes in
less than 10 milliseconds because time
is virtual so here's an implementation
you start with a traffic light
controller and you pass in a scheduler
at the top is a bunch of extension
methods provided to generate you a
mocked scheduler in reactive extensions
and you assert that a fault state should
be read read for safety that's like the
right thing to do because if something
went wrong and it was like red green
that's really bad or green green that's
really bad and then you take the
scheduler and you can tell it to advance
time you can not only forward time you
can actually rewind time with reactive
extensions you become like a complete
Time Lord there's a talk at ignite by
Joe a labarie of lint pad who talks
about becoming a Time Lord with this
thing it's on the reactive UI website
it's worth a look so at first we advance
by one second and we've gone from red
red to red green in the state machine
and then we advance it by 200
and 70 seconds so instead of this test
taking 270 seconds it's now just taking
10 milliseconds awesome
so RAM is another example
and it's over dinosaur we have a loading
indicator and whilst this command is
executing it's like a progress indicator
and typically if you're doing any form
of testing for a loading indicator you
really can't you got to wait wait
real-time especially of UI testing you
can mock in a virtual scheduler and
improve you can improve the performance
of this and it's just easy to work with
because time is testable so a common
function that people do in their
application is undo you see this in
Gmail when you compose an email it's
like be sure you want to send that email
and it gives you an undo give you an
undo operation so this is how you do
undo with reactive programming
so we have a list of dinosaurs here the
delete command is automatically enabled
because I've selected something and
that's based off a reactive command and
can execute and we've win an E and now
if I delete a dinosaur what happens is
it pops up something that's in building
to reactive you iack order interaction
and these interactions are completely
testable because you can fast forward
time you can pop an interaction and then
fast forward the clock and assert that
this was displayed for five seconds then
dismissed as a unit test not as an
integration and end test which is like
cool so if I delete this dot if I delete
the top dinosaur I got four seconds
click undo click undo go straight
straight to the top cool really easy to
implement and it's all based off the
concepts from before now resilience is
something interesting there's this
really good library the.net ecosystem
called fo D I so a very very good
library the dotnet ecosystem called
Polly and Polly allows you to construct
what you should do if there's a failure
but is the third party it is a third
party library it's not something that's
built into the design of the constructor
that you're Pro doing in so it doesn't
really fit quite naturally with a
reactive extension there's a whole bunch
of operators and one of the operators is
retry you can retry an operation by just
using the word dot retry really really
cool so baked in by default so Paul
batts recently said them reactive
extensions and when debug there's
probably three things that keep paying
off in his job for the last ten years
and they have a reputation of being hard
to learn
it's true but software engineering is
hard it is learning and the thing about
reactive programming it's the knowledge
of universal you learn it here I can now
cross over and become angular developer
quite easily in comparison I just got to
learn to express myself as a JavaScript
developer instead of a.net developer and
I typically can't say that about much
technologies so it's just it's just cool
but I kind of debate with them that it's
like hard to learn it is but I don't
think it's been taught right so this
example shown you today is coming out of
a book written by Kent Kent is one of
the other maintainer x' as of last night
he's opened up for pre-orders for the
book and let's show it shows you how to
build a reactive application using
reactive UI or just observables and the
the the demos I've been showing you is
coming from his book that's exactly what
it is and the community's been asking
for something like this for a very long
time so that's available now at reactive
UI net such book in addition the if you
ever use the if you've ever used github
for get up for Windows or in Visual
Studio you've seen this extension for
using visual 0 using github in Visual
Studio that extension is actually
written in reactive UI and the full
source code of that visual studio
plug-in which is in the visual studio
store installer is there so you even
wanted like a reference implementation
of how to unit test house over balls
what does like how do I do
oh tap authentication or like - if a in
a reactive manner every feature you see
there is right there in that source code
very very easy and that helps a lot of
people live with the transition is
seeing a fully fledged enterprise
application that's supporting production
source codes there in addition we
started collecting a lot of these videos
this video and this progress
presentation today will be there
eventually likewise we've been starting
to run virtual meetups
so we gain people all around the world
and we're learning reactive programming
together then one of the best ways of
learning reactor program is just having
someone there to teach you it's it's
just having someone to ask that question
to what if because you have to start
thinking in a different manner so I have
people who have joined in from Brazil a
remote place in France Rio - been in
Congo it's amazing
virtual meetups are going to start
become more and more of a thing because
for advanced technologies because there
still isn't enough critical mass in
thinking to hold a local meetup but
there are people all around the world
who want to learn these techniques so we
run these meetups online and the
format's working the all means project
is also doing this as well really cool
really cool and kind of enter into the
future of T of Education to make
reactive programming easier is I think
we need to get reactive UI into the web
browser not to write applications but
just for education I want someone to be
able to use reactive UI with actually
without having to download a solution
where how to compile something without
having to load up link pad just click a
link and you're running dotnet in your
web browser so Miguel last week said I
love web assembly
so I nagged him a little bit and said
xamarin workbooks needs to run in the
web browser and he goes that guy has an
ax man with a plan
so it's not official product
announcement but they're thinking about
it then a couple days ago this happened
dotnet is now running in the web browser
there was a presentation here two days
ago on blazer no blazer is not mono
it's a it's a small implementation you
can't run everything that you expect in
dotnet mono is now running in your
browser which is like the next logical
step so I run a newsletter
weakly xamarin calm if you want to keep
up to date we've liked how this is
progressing these advancements sign up
there it's just like it like a
newsletter to you from me okay because
the classic way of teaching reactive
programming is using marble diagrams and
all the innovative ways of teaching
reactive programming is all in
JavaScript now the problem with
JavaScript if your net developer is well
that's cool you tell you tell me what
that is but I can't really see the
implementation I can't really understand
that and if this continues to advance in
this direction we will soon be able to
have soon be a toehold training
educational resources to teach reactive
programming but on the left hand side
instead of rxjs
and interesting enough that is
observable from event handler that's the
JavaScript implementation in rxjs will
soon be able to teach reactive
programming in dotnet in the web browser
without the user having to do anything
and that's going to unlock a lot of
things as far as developer experience
and making it more accessible so here we
have a we have a text box any to win any
value in that text box changes I'm going
to draw a marble and that marble
represents the keystroke that I press
and that's not working so when you a
marble diagram represents a sequence of
changes over time so what was meant to
happen here in the animation is when I
press a key when I press a letter the
letter is shown and it just goes back if
I press the next character the marble
shown it just goes back it's a way of
modeling the world it's very very
powerful teaching implement so
there's a huge community behind reactor
program we all kind of hang out together
like the rxjs community in the reactive
UI community we're in one we're in the
same slack instance we see we sit there
in one channel they sit there in the
other channel and if you're looking to
get started and open source you want to
learn reactor programming I invite you
to come join us
come join us there's so many ways to
help out and open source and if you help
out we'll pay it forward on that on the
off chance that you also will pay it
forward to the next person because the
best way to learn it is together and
some of the best ways to contribute open
source are non code related there was a
recent survey by a github that says
documentation is highly valued but often
overlooked often often overlooked and
last last month have been working on
building out the reactive UI
documentation and in particular is that
there's a contributing guide now there's
even a there's even a guide for grammar
voice and tone because reactive UI is
standard generate revenue and we're
looking at maybe we can hire someone as
a tech writer overseas with a limited
budget that we have but first they need
to have some guides for contributing so
I've been mashing out this documentation
but not really following those
guidelines and people are sending in
pull requests and being my editors it's
great it's I can't even explain it it's
like the best thing in the world you
want you want to make it maintainer
happy fix the spelling mistake it's easy
to review easy to approve you've made a
contribution it's better you've helped
me we love it helped write documentation
spelling mistakes grab our you name it
even if you gets tiny it's everything
it's the best thing to fix
so I'm thank you for joining me here
today mentioned before I'm broadcasting
on YouTube sharing my knowledge
unlike Brendon who was able to offer one
direct one-on-one
some of the things I've got planned in
the roadmap I need to need to be
scalable
I've always as a maintainer I'll burn
out so anytime you ask me a question I'm
going to create a video or broadcast
live like the answer for it because
other people also going to ask those
questions so I'll direct them to that
resource so with that in play thank you
very much
[Applause]